I think we have tremendous tremendous
growth remainders tremendous potential
in exploring the frontier of human
beings we are at just at the very very
beginning of a very exciting adventure
and think of of diseases as common cold
right there is nothing terribly unusual
about common cold right yet we don't
have a cure for common cold yet which is
kind of ironic right which means that
innovation could be very small for small
things like common corn or big things
like Alzheimer's and diabetes we have
multiple products for the diabetes today
we don't have a cure for diabetes yet
actually if you add Alzheimer's and
diabetes it could bankrupt our
healthcare system yet we don't have a
cure for diabetes and we don't know how
to deal with Alzheimer's yet so if I
look at the future a couple of things
will happen one we have phenomenal tools
that will enable us to diagnose and to
be more specific in better understanding
the mechanism of virtually any disease
and the second aspect would be based on
that we can start now chartered the the
road to better understanding the brain
we don't know much about the brain we
know a few things here and there but the
brain is a huge unknown scientifically
still we don't have a lot of tools yet
to better understand how we think the
memory and everything related to our
behavior so the brain will be probably
the next frontier but we should not
forget that we have still about 6,000
rare diseases that do not have a
treatment so we have a lot of work to do
and we cannot do it alone I mean money
and the investment is one thing but we
need to continue working on the
framework of the regulatory agencies and
how we can partner with the regulators
to have a clearer path forward to having
the new drugs approved the biggest
challenge we face is science is moving
that so fast
that the regulator's have to catch up
they have to catch up to understand and
catch up even more to regulate us which
is a very daunting challenge and I
really believe that the regulator's are
doing the right things in most of the
cases but at the same time I can only
see the challenges that they have to
better understand how the science is
progressing and you hear every every
every day about the genomes and our
understanding of the genomes I mean this
is absolutely flabbergasting the
progress we made over the last 15 years
in better understanding the inner
mechanics of how we work and from there
welcomed new medications will come new
cures new treatments